[Music]
so a few years ago I went to go and
investigate rumors of hippos rogue
hippos running riot in rural Colombia
now hippos don't naturally live in South
America they are from sub-saharan Africa
and but these hippos had been
transported to Colombia by Pablo Escobar
so Pablo Escobar like many powerful men
fancied himself as a bit of a Noah's Ark
kind of twisted Noah in fact and he
wanted to build his own menagerie at
hacienda nápoles which was his ranch
where he controlled his drug empire in
between bogit our medicine in the in the
andes in colombia and legend has it that
he gathered together this menagerie by
stealing a Russian cargo plane flying it
or having it flown to Africa where he
loaded it up with loads of illegal
wildlife and then had to get it back to
Colombia before the tranquilized animals
woke up and amongst this cargo of
creatures was one male hippo that was
nicknamed el viejo and three females and
he transplanted these enormous beasts
into a pond at his Hacienda and they
loved it it turns out that Colombia is a
hippo paradise because actually all
hippos really want is some nice shallow
water to wallow around in and plenty of
grass to eat and Colombia has plenty of
that it also has no other hippos so no
other competition and no natural
predators so the hippos flourished in
their in their new paradise and very
quickly the four became aids became
twelve became sixteen and what happens
with hippos is you have a male who has a
harem so every time one of El Viejo's
sons reach sexual maturity he would boot
him out the
and and that young male hippo would then
head off in search of hippo love
elsewhere now of course in Africa this
is completely normal
hippos head off from their their family
group and young males will go in search
of hippo love and and and and start
their own family but of course in
Colombia there are no hippos out there
so these males these young males are
being spirited away from hacienda
nápoles in one of the many many rivers
in that part of colombia which acts like
sort of hippo superhighway so they're
sort of pinging them out into the
countryside and then they arrive and
they can't find a mate so they think
they're quite cantankerous beasts at the
best of times but these are sort of
frank frustrated horny male hippos
desperately looking for love where there
is none I I went to Colombia to
investigate this story and visit it one
of these rogue males that had installed
himself in a pond next to a kindergarten
I've met the kids from the school who
told me that they no longer liked to
bathe in that particular pond - right
and one of them told me about how his
grandmother have been chased by the
lovelorn beast for quite some time that
the earlier in the week so they are
they're kind of running a mock basically
so you know what do you do with this
situation you've got you know rapidly
multiplying hippos and the extraordinary
thing about what's happening in Colombia
is it's changing their behavior because
in Africa you have this very fierce dry
season which you know puts the brakes on
hippo reproduction so I think they they
reach sexual maturity you know I don't
know I can't remember it's like five or
seven years let's say
but in Colombia they were reaching
sexual maturity significantly earlier
and having babies every year instead of
every two years so they were multiplying
at this much faster rate because they
didn't have this
constraints on them that they do in
Africa so you've got a bit of a problem
you've got a massive invasive species
now with most invasive species the
solution is to get rid of them because
basically they upset ecosystems and and
so they need to be removed but the
problem with hippos though is that they
star in Disney movies so there is this
sort of rogue male and the first one
that they they they put down there's a
public outcry and so they had to come up
with a different plan and I met with the
Colombian vet who was in charge of
implementing the radical plan B which
was the castration program so Carlos
Valderrama was given the ownerís task of
having to castrate one of these rogue
males now this I am sure you can
appreciate as a job that takes a fair
amount of cojones
because castrating a wild male hippo is
no easy task it is actually unbelievably
complicated
first of all hippos because they've got
so much fat they're really hard to
anesthetize because the anaesthetic
dissolves in the fat so even though
they're enormous you have to get the
dosage right they also when they're
nervous they go into water you don't
want it to pass out in the water because
it's going to drown then when you
finally manage to anis it Carlos said to
me he had and also they're really really
really aggressive then Carlos told me
that he had decoy Cowboys and and all
sorts of shenanigans to try and just to
get through the anaesthetic stage then
the clock was on they had a certain
amount of time in order to complete the
castration
now the thing about hippos is they are
the closest relative of the hippo is the
whale they have internal
testicles that are buried underneath
about eight inches of skin and fat not
only that but hippo testicles have a
habit of wandering about when under
threat they can move as much as eight
centimeters so you're looking at a blank
canvas behind which there's a moving
target now when you get in there they're
the size of cantaloupes but just getting
to them and working out where to make
the incision and then managing to grab
hold of these moving melons and getting
them out this was quite some task and
it's apparently it took him about six
hours and it cost well over a hundred
thousand dollars so you know I think
they've managed to do one more
subsequently but they're never going to
it's just it's too difficult they're
never going to be able to castrate all
the males that's just not going to
happen what I think is gonna happen is
we're gonna have a new subspecies of
Columbian hippo before too long
hippopotamus s cabarrus because that's
how you make a new species you take you
put it in isolation from its parent
species and and it evolves into a
slightly different different species and
that's what's going to happen the hippo
is always being quoted as being Africa's
most dangerous animal now I I did some
digging around I've never really been
able to find out the source of this fact
but I can tell you having been charged
by a hippo myself they are really really
really dangerous I mean they they do
kill people they are extremely
aggressive they move really fast the the
male that we went to go and film the
rogue male in Colombia he we got a
little bit too close and he was in his
pond and he came towards us with such
velocity that they were barrel waves
coming off his coming off his nose he
hurtled through the water it was pretty
terrifying I can tell you so the thing
about hippos is they are that they're
really dangerous so they're dangerous to
humans in Colombia who don't understand
how dangerous they are because
culturally they haven't grown up
alongside hippo
I've seen them in Disney films they
think they chubby and cute Carlos told
me that this is this is a real issue but
also of course they are ecosystem
engineers and one of the things about
hippos is that they you know the eager
animals they churn up a lot of
vegetation they have the power to
reshape their environment and it's this
reshaping of the environment that was
that was most alarming to Carlos
Valderrama because he was worried that
other native species that share the
rivers like manatees for instance would
would suffer with hippos being around
[Music]